eso
[Música]
se imaginan ustedes competir con los con
los animales para poder conseguir agua
al principio en los años 90 yo trabajaba
en una ong que se dedicaba al desarrollo
al desarrollo rural y yo estaba
responsable siendo responsable de
infraestructura quiere decir que me
encargaba de ver los canales de riego
los sistemas de agua y normalmente
recorríamos las comunidades
y muchas veces nos quedamos a dormir en
ellas
en uno de estos días yo visité una
comunidad que se llama lickley conga que
da frente a las ventanillas de otuzco
que es una zona turística de cajamarca
en la parte alta
y tuve que quedarme a dormir en esta
comunidad las habitaciones en la zona
rural es una sola habitación donde todos
duermen inclusive los invitados se
comparten la habitación
y eso es las tres de la mañana escuché
bulla
me preocupe y le dije si pasaba algo si
podría ayudar en algo y lo que me
señalaron es no no se preocupe ingeniero
siga durmiendo porque vamos a traer el
agua
esto me dio curiosidad y les dije si
podría acompañar los aceptaron entonces
nos fuimos llegamos a un manantial
manantial pequeño ya habían algunas
personas de la comunidad haciendo su
cola para abastecerse de agua
y les pregunté por qué la necesidad de
venir a las tres de la mañana a llevar
el agua porque en lo más tarde
lo que me contestaron fue tiene que ser
a las tres porque a eso de las cuatro y
media cinco a la mañana ya vienen los
animales
vienen los perros las ovejas las vacas a
tomar agua de ese manantial que ellos
consumiendo
por supuesto los animales se ensuciaban
todo eso
y por supuesto ensuciaban el agua
esto sinceramente fue lo que me marcó
para que yo me decida a buscar
soluciones en agua y saneamiento y
colaborar con la gente de la zona rural
para que se abastezcan de agua
era indignante pensar
que la población de esa comunidad tenía
que competir con los animales para poder
abastecerse de agua
dicho esto
en el perú les quiero informar que
existen 8 millones de personas que viven
en la zona rural 2 millones no tienen
acceso al agua potable y de los 6
millones que sí tienen acceso al agua
potable
solamente el 2% consume agua de calidad
mejor dicho el resto de personas
consumen agua entubada eso quiere decir
que dos personas de cada 100 consumen
agua de calidad ustedes se pueden
imaginar esta realidad
mi intención entonces reforzó buscar
soluciones para evitar ver esta figura
no es posible que los seres humanos
estén tomando agua en estas condiciones
cuáles son las consecuencias de esto
las consecuencias según el banco mundial
es que hay una relación directa y esto
lo ha demostrado por muchos estudios
entre el abastecimiento al agua potable
y las enfermedades diarreicas agudas la
mortalidad infantil y principalmente la
desnutrición crónica infantil la
desnutrición crónica infantil afecta
directamente la capacidad cognoscitiva
de los niños entonces no esperemos que
los niños que no tienen acceso a agua de
calidad rindan en la escuela o en el
colegio esto es un gran problema que me
afectó sinceramente y es por eso que yo
después entró a trabajar a water for
people water for people es una ong
americana que lo que busca es cobertura
a todas las personas con agua potable
bajo un lema que es every one forever
para todos para siempre pero el trabajo
se tiene que hacer en alianza en alianza
con la municipalidad con la comunidad en
alianza con el gobierno y con el sector
privado es indispensable
en el perú muchas veces durante los
últimos años se han hecho grandes
inversiones pero en mejoramiento y
rehabilitación de sistemas de agua
potable rurales es poca la inversión que
se ha hecho en la inversión para las
personas que no tienen agua
entonces para enfrentar este problema
como water for people nosotros
proponemos tres factores indispensables
y dotarlo de una buena infraestructura
que lleve como complemento una buena
capacitación a la organización priorizar
a las personas que no han sido 'la que
no es que no están siendo abastecidas y
pensar en el medio ambiente
vamos a hablar cada una de ellas
priorizar a las personas que no tienen
agua es necesario que las inversiones
que se hagan tienen que atender a las
personas que no tienen agua esto
nosotros lo hemos aplicado en asuncion
un distrito de cajamarca donde hemos
tenido que fortalecer las capacidades de
las municipalidades dar asistencia
técnica a las municipalidades para que
gestionen y orienten recursos
financieros al sector saneamiento pero
además hemos tenido que trabajar con las
comunidades para que haya un nivel de
presión social hacia la municipalidad y
le exija el derecho de tener agua
luego como vemos nosotros la
sostenibilidad la sostenibilidad la
consideramos de que debe haber una buena
infraestructura donde son los
manantiales se construyó una captación
que luego se tiende la tubería y se
lleva a un reservorio y de este
reservorio por medio de tuberías también
se distribuye a todas las casas pero
solamente la infraestructura no es
suficiente y aquí tenemos que ser muy
específicos para que esta
infraestructura funcione se necesita
capacitar a los comités de agua potable
el comité de agua potable
es elegido en una asamblea general por
la comunidad y son personas que se van a
encargar de administrar mantener y
operar estos sistemas
pero hay que enseñarles a estos señores
cuáles son las partes del sistema cómo
es que se opera cómo es que se coloca el
cloro para purificar el agua todas está
esta parte llamamos la capacitación en
administración operación y mantenimiento
a los comités de agua potable
pero la infraestructura no es lo
suficiente es necesario complementar con
una capacitación a dos actores claves el
comité de agua potable pero también la
familia me explico si nosotros tenemos
una buena infraestructura y tenemos un
comité de agua potable bien capacitado
tendremos un sistema sostenible pero no
nos aseguramos de que haya impacto en la
vida de las personas qué pasa si yo
tengo un sistema de agua potable bien
construido hay agua las 24 horas las
familias pagan pagan la cuota familiar
pero viene un niño o una niña que sale
del baño coge una taza sucia y se sirve
el agua y la toma prácticamente no hemos
hecho nada allí es que toma prioridad la
educación sanitaria que tiene que ver
básicamente con los cambios de hábito de
higiene en las familias el lavado de
manos consumo de agua segura a
disposición de excretas disposición de
residuos sólidos
este es el punto en que hace que un
sistema sostenible tenga el impacto
positivo en las familias
y pensando a futuro nosotros tenemos que
pensar en que estos manantiales se
encuentran dentro de un espacio
geográfico que se llama cuenca la cuenca
es este espacio geográfico donde fluyen
todos los las corrientes de agua fluyen
bajan por quebradas y terminan en un
solo río
pero de dónde viene el agua que llega a
estas cuencas todo el agua que llega a
estas cuencas viene de la lluvia de la
precipitación generalmente estas
precipitaciones se dan en la parte alta
de la cuenca en el caso específico del
perú se dan entre los meses de noviembre
a abril generalmente ese es el rango en
donde se concentra al caer el agua en
estas cuencas en las partes altas de las
cuencas ocurren dos cosas parte del agua
baja por las quebradas a los ríos y
muchas veces se pierde en el mar
pero el factor más importante es que la
otra parte de agua se infiltra en el
suelo pero ahí tenemos que estar bien
cuidadosos con lo que tenemos que
analizar
si tenemos un suelo con cobertura
vegetal
va a haber mayor retención de agua y
como ocurre esto
la cobertura vegetal ustedes saben que
las plantas tienen raíces a través de
las raíces es que se alimentan no es
cierto para que la para que la planta se
alimente absorbe el agua lo que ocurre
es que al ser millones de raíces a la
vez hay una gran fuerza de absorción y
de retención del agua eso es lo que hace
que el agua se almacene dentro del suelo
y la naturaleza valga la redundancia
naturalmente distribuye estas aguas las
va soltando y salen en la superficie a
través de los manantiales ese es el
ciclo que pasa en el flujo del agua
dentro de un terreno pero si este
terreno no tiene cobertura vegetal
simplemente el agua cae y escurre
superficialmente o puede ocurrir parte
por la parte subterránea pero va a
terminar en ríos y quebradas y termina
en el mar sin ser utilizada
cómo podemos enfrentar esto nosotros la
propuesta que tenemos es la siembra y
cosecha de agua que se llama la siembra
y cosecha de agua es como logramos que
la gran cantidad de agua que acá en la
parte alta de la cuenca se infiltra en
el suelo y ahí se almacene para hacer
esto hay una serie de prácticas que se
llaman prácticas conservacionistas que
están desde la forestación la siembra de
árboles las zanjas de infiltración las
terrazas de formación lenta o las aminas
es una técnica que se está practicando
aquí en el perú también esto permitiría
que el suelo almacene una mayor cantidad
de agua a esto le llamamos siembra y
cosecha de agua siembra cuando tratamos
de retener el agua en el en el suelo y
la cosecha cuando ésta sale por los
manantiales y es aprovechada en este
caso específico para los sistemas de
agua potable
esto nosotros lo hemos hecho en asunción
hay una comunidad que se llama sapu
donde facilita nosotros lo único que
hemos hecho es facilitar la relación
entre los agricultores que utilizan agua
para riego los usuarios de agua potable
que utilizan el agua para con sus manos
y los ganaderos que utilizan agua para
para su para su ganado se han puesto de
acuerdo y están haciendo trabajos de
reforestación ahí estamos viendo el
vivero que tienen ellos en común y van a
hacer trabajos de reforestación en las
partes altas para aumentar la retención
de la entonces concluyendo si nosotros
queremos que todas las personas tengan
agua necesitamos primero priorizar a las
personas que no tienen agua tenemos que
hacer las inversiones necesarias en eso
pero brindándoles un sistema sostenible
eso quiere decir una buena
infraestructura que tenga
sistema un sistema de agua potable
construido con calidad con capacitación
en administración operación y
mantenimiento al comité de agua potable
y con educación sanitaria dirigida a la
familia y complementario a esto
comenzará a trabajar todo lo que es la
parte medioambiental con la siembra y
cosecha de agua de esta manera podemos
nosotros tener agua para siempre para
todos el deber iván forever gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]